Bree is in New York hi Bree welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave thanks for
taking my call
sure what's up my boyfriend and I have
been dating for five years and against
your better wisdom we had been shacked
up for three of those during this time I
have had a career conundrum and so I had
been working various jobs in order to
keep going on my baby steps my question
is he is frustrated that I'm working so
much if it's not involved in a
particular career that I'm aiming to
pursue so he has offered to either
combine our finances or give me a
stipend a month so that I can work less
and focus on you know figure out what it
is I want to do for a career I do not
want to combine our finances nor my okay
with receiving a stipend and so my
question is how do I you know try to
work 11 or 12 hours a day but also be
pursuing something else why don't you
get married
that's a good question
he said that we should just combine our
finances so that we can test everything
out before we get married
you've been kind of doing that right
usually you've been doing that for three
years right and legally like you a bunch
of times like there's no protection yep
you know in case you were to break up
well here's the thing it also changes
the it bless his heart he's trying okay
but what he what he just said was I'm
gonna pay you to live with me that's
what you heard and that's what I heard
but he didn't mean that okay but but
that that when you start this down this
road a stipend seriously is that not
just a little bit insulting to a girl I
mean come on you're about as romantic as
an actuarial I mean gosh unbelievable
yeah so I don't want to be like if you
want it put a ring on it you know that's
not very romantic either but at the same
time it's guy like I don't know I feel
like I'm in a lose-lose situation where
I want to keep you know pushing for my
baby stuff
pingas Ellington yeah and I don't feel
like that I you know you guys have got
to decide what you're going to do my
advice to you would be get married
you've been living together three years
you've been dating five years I think
we've established a level of
compatibility go get some pre marriage
counseling and get married and then that
solves this whole issue that's my advice
to you it's not put a ring on it but
it's just a matter of you're already
doing everything associated with
marriage except you don't have the legal
benefits and and it creates a weird
relationship dynamic when someone you're
not married to is paying you and you
live with them I mean that's just kinda
feels weird doesn't it I mean it just it
more and I understand he doesn't mean it
that way but it's almost like he's you
know paying you you know that's just
weird you don't you don't want it you
don't be that girl for sure you know so
and he doesn't mean it that way but it
shifts the dynamic in this and so I you
know if I were in your shoes I'd get
married that's what I would do I'd get
some pre marriage counseling see if
there's any toxic stuff left in this
relationship short and I'm talking like
September my thumb about September of
2019 either but this one so five years
is enough really it's done the painter
get off the ladder really you gotta
decide what's going on here this is the
Dave Ramsey show